hi everyone this it's my great pleasure
to actually introduce mark leave it was
has been a great pleasure working with
them over the summer and he's going to
talking about his evaluation of software
tools for the annotation of sequence
parents thank you Christina so my name
is Mark and my presentation is titled
evaluation of software tools for the
annotation of sequence variants for
clinical sequencing so let's get into
this rather meaty title and start
breaking down some terms first of all
what is clinical sequencing clinical
sequencing is one night's such at our
lab such as the night diagnostic lab
takes samples from a cancer patients
tumor and sequences it they take that
sequence line it up against a reference
genome human reference genome and then
use a variety of algorithms called
variant calling algorithms to identify
places in the sequences where there is
variation and these result in what we
call variants so the data set that I
worked with for the summer consisted of
18 of these variants and just to give
you sort of a better idea of what
exactly these mean if you take the first
row you can think of the variant a like
a genome address so for the first row on
chromosome 1 at that monstrously large
number position there is a C in the
human reference and in the sample taken
from the tumor there is a tee this is
what we call a variant and what do we
want to know about this variant that's
exactly what variant annotation is as
you can infer from the name it involves
attaching relevant and useful bits of
information to regions of the genome so
you can make conclusions about variants
that fall within those regions these
annotations can include things like like
a basic annotation that was on the last
slide such as which gene does the
variant fall into is this variant within
a coding region things of that nature
there are also functional annotations
what biochemical function does this
region serve
and the end goal of variant annotation
is using this information to tie
specific variants to various aspects of
a disease the disease progression the
root causes of these diseases and if
you've heard the term personalized
medicine well this is essentially
personalized medicine using patient
specific variation to infer unique
methods of treatment and basically gain
insight into not just the disease in
general but the disease specified to
that patient so my job for the summer
was reviewing software tools that
perform these sort of annotations there
are a number of these tools out there
and they all do different things the
first two tools polyphen and sift are
variant effect predictors and what these
tools do is take in a number of variants
and will basically algorithmically
provide a prediction about whether this
variant will have a harmful or no effect
on the protein that encompasses it
another different category of tool is
cool bar this tools tents for
co-occurring variant analyzer when
variants are looked at they usually
looked at individually which is not a
very realistic context what Kivar does
is look at all these variants
simultaneously which is a much more
realistic take on what's going on a
regulan DB is a database which consists
of regulatory information a lot of
variants are provided mainly for coding
regions things within genes and proteins
things of that nature regular MDB is
sort of gives you a broader scope of
annotations and the rest of these tools
that I've sort of named whole genome
annotation suites are sort of a mishmash
of these features they sort of combine
functional effect predictors with
information aggregates and sort of
assemble a number of different
annotations as well as providing some
sort of interpretation of these
annotations so when I was reviewing a
tool there were a number of
considerations that I focused on um the
first was the usage model him is there a
website for this tool is a command
line tool do I have to download anything
things of that nature ease of use was
another big one do I have to have a
working understanding of the perl
programming language to configure this
tool do i have to download hundreds of
gigabytes of databases onto my computer
do i need a lot of training in genetics
and biology to interpret the results
these are all very important
considerations data security was another
big one since we're working with patient
data and it's very sensitive we'd rather
not have it lying on a strange server
somewhere just because we queried a tool
speed was another important factor my
dataset was only 18 variants but variant
calls can produce millions of variants
potentially so being productive
productively annotating these variants
in a timely fashion was another very
important consideration annotations
provided was also very important
obviously which databases is the tool
using to aggregate information what sort
of annotations exactly are provided and
finally a uniqueness factor and the
uniqueness factor was something that I
really focused on because a lot of these
tools have overlapping function they
pool from the same databases they use
the same scores and so a unique factor
characteristic about that tool was
something that really made it stand out
as there was a lot of overlap in
functionality so my method was pretty
straightforward I would read the journal
article written by the creators of the
tool I would read the tool documentation
so I could better understand how to use
the tool how to interpret the input and
output things like that I would then use
the tool to annotate my data set of 18
variants I would collect notes about
these annotations and I would compile
the findings as a PowerPoint
presentation so one of the first tools i
reviewed sift which stands for sorts
intolerant from tolerant and what that
refers to is intolerant variants from
tolerant variants intolerant variants
meeting this variant adversely affects
the function of the protein that
encompasses it and tolerant meaning a
change does occur but the protein still
functions normally this is a software
tool that gives you a prediction in that
regard
and sift primarily makes its decisions
based on evolutionary conservation so a
good way to think about that is giraffes
have very long necks to reach food at
the top of the trees and giraffes with
shorter necks died out evolutionary has
deemed the long-necked trait to be
important similarly there are regions of
sequence that persevere across
generations and sometimes across species
in a similar family that we can
similarly say evolution has deemed
important so we refer to it as conserved
so for example here are a number of
species of bacteria on the left hand
side and these are their their sequences
and you can see regions where there are
greater similarity and regions where
there's far less similarity and how sift
functions is say this variant s over
here is entered into sift and this
region as much is very low has a low
conservation rate so sift will determine
this variant would be accepted because
this portion of the sequence is a much
more open to change it fluctuates a lot
more evolution has not deemed it very
important for instance if we look at the
variant down there that red column
filled with ELLs if we were to make a
change in that portion of the sequence
shift would probably say this is going
to have a damaging effect this is a
conserved region evolution has deemed
this sequence to be important thus this
is going to be problematic if when this
variant occurs so the next brand of
tools i reviewed genome annotation
suites as i mentioned earlier sort of i
classify the information they provided
into these four sort of umbrella terms
the first is the context physically
where does it fall into the genome is it
within a gene as it within an x on how
many genes does it overlap transcript
information things like that the
predicted effect a lot of these tools
had pre computed sift scores and
polyphen which is another functional
predictor as well as making as well as
other methods of predicting the effect
of a variant based on the annotations
that it a grenade it and finally our
population diversity is another
consideration does this variant occur
across populations how how
often does it occur things like that
known disease associations has this
variant been attributed to been known to
be associated with diseases in the past
and so all these annotations are
provided so one of the favorite tools
and the one I'm going to focus on now is
called vario watch and this is just this
is a view from vario watch that provides
some insight into the context and so why
would we want to know about the context
well from this we can see those two
little green triangles in the middle are
to the variance from my data set we can
see that it falls within a coding region
and knowing the context is very
important is it in a regulatory region
will this either cause gene expression
to increase or decrease is this business
within a coding region is this going to
cause a protein to malfunction or
continue to behave normally or possibly
behave weirdly we know that what gene
this falls into so based the context is
a very good relatively basic annotation
that we can determine about our variant
population diversity is probably the
next one I like to think of the reason
population diversity is important is for
investigating a rare illness of some
kind something that occurs very
infrequently and we have a variant say
at the top C and G so in the reference
it is a sea and in the sample taken from
the patient it's a jeep and so what this
tells us is that we're trying to tie
these variants to a rare disease but our
variant occurs across populations 28 in
twenty eight percent of people in
sixty-six percent of people so it's
unlikely that a variant that occurs in
sixty-six percent of the population is
going to be related to this rare illness
that we're investigating so very a watch
provides a number of nice aesthetically
pleasing graphics options to view your
variance you can get a nice chromosome
wide view up at the top and you can
actually go to the specific gene to the
specific transcript all the way down to
the variant and what very watch does is
classify as a variant
with a risk level it's low risk it's
medium risk it's very high risk and one
of the things that I really liked about
very watches its transparency this at
the very bottom here is a risk level
decision tree which I'll get into more
later this is my data set in burial
watch sort of a chromosome wide view of
where everything falls as well as it's
color-coded by the risk level so if we
wanted to investigate more about why
very a watch made a decision for
instance on chromosome 17 it classified
one of my variants as very high risk we
could click on it and would actually
give you this is what I mentioned
earlier risk level decision tree which
sort of shows you the algorithms thought
process in making its decision to
classify the variant this way is it in a
coding region yes it is so is it a
nonsynonymous change nonsynonymous means
that nucleotide change affects the amino
acid so the protein sequence actually
changes the synonymous change changes
the nucleotide a CTR g but does not
affect the protein sequence of amino
acids and finally is this a nonsense
mutation nonsense mutations are when a
premature stop codon is formed which
means that the protein is basically its
manufacturing is halted early so it can
be malformed and def will probably
malfunction so we can see very watch
there's a lot of transparency in this
tool some of the tools would just spit
back oh this variant is high risk and
then you really have no way of
determining where that decision came
from and burial watch had a really good
transparency in that regard so at the
end of the summer I was asked to sort of
aggregate information from the various
tools and make a conclusion about each
variant as to whether in further
investigation was needed and so
basically here's one example when I just
showed you the nonsense mutation this is
that variant you can see that both sift
and polyphen identified it as a damaging
do to stop barrier watch classified it
is very high risk and snip nexus another
one of the tools are reviewed reported
that this variant had been previous
previously associated with a number of
cancers so
the consensus here was pretty easy to
determine that this variant was probably
worth continued research and
investigation based on the conclusions
of a number of tools sort of agreeing
that this was a potentially harmful
variant but it wasn't always that easy
there was there were times when the
tools would disagree with each other
which is we're very watches transparency
was very useful so here we see sift and
polyphen both reported this to be a
synonymous mutation meaning once again
that the nucleotide changed but the
protein sequence remained intact and so
no adverse effects were predicted but
regular MDB which was as I mentioned
earlier a tool that aggregated
regulatory information outside of the
coding scope reported that there were
some elements there and similarly very a
watch reported that this was a high-risk
variant so going into vario watches
decision tree we can actually see that
it agreed with regulatory DB and that
there were some regulatory elements
being affected so all in all I mentioned
earlier burial watch I found to be the
best all-around tool in terms of
usability and annotations provided it
was a nice medium snip Nexus provided
the greatest number of useful
annotations but wasn't most
user-friendly and sift polyphen I
determined to be really excellent first
steps for giving you an idea of
functional significance of a variant
finally I just like to thank Kristina
being a wonderful mentor and teacher and
the demise for giving me this
opportunity thank you very much
anyway how many questions yeah so when
you identify these variants who's the
the user that you want to convey this to
and and what do they do with it is it
researchers who are studying these
things or clinicians who may alter their
therapy based on genomic findings or
both right now these tools are used in
research but have not reached the
clinical level of use yet this comes
from the fact that a lot of these
annotations provided and a lot of these
predictions are exactly that their
predictions so they're more it's more
giving the researcher a bunch of clues
with which they can use to make their
own conclusion rather than definitive
evidence for a variant this variant
causes this disease and that nature so
right now this is primarily for
researchers yes
great talk by the way did any of these
software packages handle variants other
than like single nucleotide kind of
variants yes the co-occurring variant
analyzer that I mentioned briefly
handled insertions and deletions but by
and large those were lacking from a lot
of the tools they were specifically
changes there wasn't a lot of actually I
don't think I think Kivar was the only
tool i reviewed that annotated in dells
yeah yes so one thing that struck me is
there's a proliferation of tools which
indicates this might be in an earlier
stage of developing these tools but
there's a ton of knowledge you have to
apply against this I wonder if you can
comment as you went through this if you
found some tools that were the cost
money or basically we're trying to get
take define resources or apply resources
to build more complex useful tools or if
these were all sort of free and
available and developed through from
other researchers these were all the
ones I looked at were developed
academically and we're all free to use
Christina maybe you can comment on if as
far as the commercialization of these
tools if there's any corporate interest
in developing things like this and not
so sure maybe you're right your
assessment of this right it's really in
the early stages so there are very few
commercially available ones and its
really nice infancy yeah how did you
resolve conflicts I mean you had one
case where the predictions seem to
disagree did you just take them you know
the most serious looking prediction or
did you you know I mean databases have
mistakes in them and so how do you know
which is which is right you know oh well
the example I showed was more a
dissonance between what the tool looked
for then actual contradictory reports so
sift and polyphen work within the coding
scope and the variants that they were
disagreeing on were had to do with
didn't have to do with proteins
it had to do with regulation so that i
resolved it that way I didn't have any
clear instances where 11 said this is a
like toss out this variant it's
extremely low risk and other things
we're reporting this is extremely
damaging but the way I would counter
that is by simply incorporating more
tools more annotations the better but
when it comes down to it there you know
if you have to make a decision whether
toss out of area nor pursue the only
thing that I can think of was just would
just be to aggregate more annotations
about that yeah in any of these tools
did you notice if any of them did a good
job with kind of keeping track of the
provenance of kind of where the
annotations are coming from so well
actually another I didn't mention it but
another reason why very a watch was my
favorite was because I can go back the
tree that I showed you at any point at
any for instance you were to click on
the coding portion it will actually
provide a reference to the it will take
you there to the database to the tool
that it used and this was very useful
tantamount actually because I mean these
could all be where is it getting this
information very important so if you
want to find out there's a there's a
motif that was diminished it would take
you to the tool or to the database where
essentially like a citation so every
step has a citation in this tool does
that get saved into some kind of final
output file that you can go back to
later on this is the online interface
but there are downloadable CSV files
that do contain this information yep did
you code mostly in our or did you have
to use pearl I didn't really have to do
much coding work I poked around in the
code of a few of these tools a lot of
them are written in perl which is very
popular language in biomedical
applications a few were written in java
and they advertise that fact a lot
because it'd provide
at a considerable speed boost over other
tools using one of those not being
programming languages but I didn't have
to do a lot of coding this summer thank
you very much
Oh
is that good for everybody all right
okay um it's my pleasure to introduce
Katie Abraham's she has worked this
summer as a summer intern I'm Karen Aunt
Karen Eden's grant and I have worked
with her on the programming aspect of
this grant katie is a computer science
student at Portland State and she's
actually truly a computer scientist
because she's shown that she is really
interested in computers she is an
excellent problem solver and she picks
up new technology probably out as fast
as anyone I've ever met so she's going
to tell you about what she's done this
summer to help with the mammography
decision aid that Karen's group has been
developing thank you so much Michelle so
as Michelle said the summer I worked
with dr. Eden doctor I bar and Lindsey
Watson who's going to present next to
develop a decision II called memo pad to
help women decide when to start getting
mammograms and I know that coding asked
for takes on multiple meetings here at
ohsu which i discovered the summer so
yes I'll today I'll be talking about
coding in the computer science sense and
today I'll introduce what a decision aid
is I'll give a brief overview of current
mammography research and then I'll talk
about our project in my role on
development so decision aid is a tool to
present and clarify and intervention or
decision to be made and ideally they
give evidence and options as well as
potential outcomes to help guide a
healthcare decision they also have the
user identify their personal values
vision aids are supposed to facilitate
communication and treatment they are not
designed to present one solution make
the choice for you order a place a
health care professional decision aid I
worked on the summer is as I had to help
women of average risk in their 40s as I
whether they want to start marrow
grammas in the 40s or wait until their
50s our decision is well as a web
application optimized for the ipad mini
so the current research or mog raphy
says that one of averages for breast
cancer should definitely begin to start
getting mammograms in their 50s though
the jury sort about whether it's every
one year or two years but there's no
expert consensus on sorry in their 40s
some say it's beneficial and can catch
cancer early and save lives while other
say that it could lead the unnecessary
expense or treatment for patients so our
app presents information in the form of
text and graphics so users can make an
informed decision based on their values
and current evidence these two graphics
as well as the image on the previous
slide or an example of how we presented
evidence to the users these two graphics
on this screen present statistics
supported by an image we wanted to show
the information in multiple ways to
reinforcement to make it easy to
understand in this case it contrasts the
risk levels of average risk women
forgetting breast cancer in the 40s
versus in their 50s as these two
graphics show that wrist elbows over
those ten years so my role in the
project was to testament portions of the
application which involved a lot of HTML
CSS and JavaScript and I also hope to
revise content so community science is
full of abbreviations and a lot of which
are opaque as i mentioned Fumero pad we
used a lot of HTML CSS and JavaScript I
want to give a quick overview I'll
probably some of you may be familiar
with these but just in case I don't want
to talk about a lot of acronyms without
anyone knowing I'm talking about so HTML
is a language for creating websites it's
the skeleton and style of website and it
provides underlying structure and
formatting CSS is a language for
configuring and changing the look of a
webpage it's what makes website look
nice and its use kind of streamlined the
design process when you're making a
webpage javascript is used to interact
with the user to create dynamic content
for our purposes anything it needs to
change after the page have been loaded
in our app which done via JavaScript for
example in an earlier version of our app
we had a sorting activity in which users
sorted their priorities about mammograms
in our health by clicking and dragging
boxes on a page and this was later
changed with selectable set of boxes so
for a simple example the top image is a
piece of HTML source code that was the
basis for an intro screen in our app
using HTML with no styling the rendered
web page looks like the bottom image
which is not too interesting
now up the top on this page is if it's
piece of CSS source code which was also
applied to that same intro screen CSS
uses rules applied to portions of a
website to dictate styling as you can
see the source code wasn't really
designed PowerPoint mind but I wanted to
give idea of the stark difference
between the source code and product and
the bottom image is what the final
interesting it looks like once all those
HTML and CSS is applied so using HTML
and CSS i modified the look of the app
adding features and making changes at
the test users or our team has something
lacking most of the modifications I made
to the app related to usability we
wanted to have to be straightforward
easy to use and informative even for
women with limited technical healthcare
experience we use feedback from test
users and usability to determine what we
needed to add or change I help with
layout changes in color or text and also
hope to implement some of new features
like a report or glossary which I'll
talk about in just a second so the
report to start off is generated at the
end of the application so users can
access information from the app at a
later date we up with the report in PDF
form with the idea that users can email
it or print it for their own use and the
clinic can attach it to an electronic
health record and we also put a note
saying you can bring this to your doctor
and then hopefully that would start a
conversation about their treatment sir
on the next slide this is an example of
the first page of the report a couple
different versions the first version
that we mocked up was on the left and
then the current version we're using
right now is on the right the report
combines informational content with
content specific to the user such as
their concern to questions about
mammograms which the dynamic content
appears in italics and there was some
surprising revisions when we made the
report in testing in the interviews that
lens is going to talk about women
brought up the fact they didn't have a
doctor and so they're unsure what to do
about questions relating to talking to
their physician so we change the wording
to reflect that it might just be general
questions and I've circled those changes
on the report to make it a little bit
easier to see the report had some
surprise and challenges on the software
side as well
since as it turns out PDF generation
isn't a built-in functionality for any
languages we're using but thankfully
people who develop useful software love
to share it and we're able to add in
report generation using the external
software library the mark speech
reminded me at the importance of
documentation one of the some of the
tools we tried to use had very very
little documentation so it a very
interesting to try to adapt those and
adapting already developed software to
provide a tool can be tricky so they
report with or number of revisions so
much in the glossary earlier I also
helped with coding that we implemented
this to improve ease of understanding
people using the app if there are any
terms they didn't understand one of them
to be able to really easily without
stopping using the app kind of be able
to find a definition that was on a plan
language so these words that they were
in the glossary appeared as blue
hyperlinks which would trigger pop up
when clicked the top image is this to
page with some various words how they've
glossary terms and the bottom is the
demonstrates the glossary different or
biopsy you can just really easily close
and keep using the app so I learned
quite a lot of summer both about
programming languages and software
development I want how to code websites
and how to make use of user feedback
while still keeping in mind the
project's goals making the best use of
feedback from apt users can be
deceptively difficult to do especially
within the timeline constraints of a
project and there are many many steps
from proving software usability in our
case wanted to run an app according to
the decision aid protocols well still
make it accessible to the target
audience the first edition of the app
which was made actually before I came on
board was vetted many many times under
grown divisions at each step some design
elements worked and say with the app for
the entire development cycle but far
more often they changed often
dramatically I learned that it's very
important to listen to your users they
haven't been staring at the software for
six weeks and that suffering from tunnel
vision and that comes with trying to
perfect a little aspect of the software
and hearten to remember but easy to
forget when you think hours of work into
something some aspects of development
only to find it's not effective it can
be very discouraging
but listening to feedback and keeping
the goals of the project in mind which
in this case and in many cases is to
help people the ultimately yields a much
better piece of software and also the
summer I was able to help dr. Eden in
dr. of R with three other research
projects including that data entry for
grant submission for the peak or k12
grant survey scanning for middle school
project that was done earlier and for my
Nana journal submission I gotta look
into the exacting standards the govern
academic research and our projects are
developed revised and processed I had
never seen the development set of
research I'd really only see what's
already been published and available to
the public so this is a really
interesting look into the world of
academic research I really want to thank
the man up had dev team for working with
the summer my fellow interns for into
their projects and do you my sandwiches
you for hosting us any questions oh yeah
I'm curious what was your user
population like oh yeah well ultimately
we want this apt to be available to
women in probably a little bit lower
income bracket work and I really search
to the orphan clinics and Lindsay's
going to talk a lot more about that but
the standards that we wanted to keep to
for the app work out plain language
which was eighth grade education we're
not we're expecting a little bit of
variation with the education level so
people again we using it but definitely
rural clinics and that sort of thing and
this may ultimately get released to the
public but right now that's our focus
population yes so I think many of us can
relate to your experience of staring at
the software for six weeks or six years
and being discouraged by people not
understanding it one of the challenges
though that it seems your face and you
address this a little but maybe a good
comment on it further is that there's so
many different types of users everyone
from a
you know a professional highly educated
woman who you know knows a lot about you
know mammography and those sorts of
things to those who are relatively
uneducated did you what experiences or
what challenges did you find trying to
create a tool for such a wide audience
oh definitely that that's a very good
question and I think that we sort of we
definitely wanted to keep it very user
friendly so we err on the side of
providing more information worse if
women were very educated mammograms they
may get information already saw but we
really didn't want anyone to be in the
dark and for this I think and maybe it
maybe Liz I was a little bit more about
this is work and the project a little
longer but I think that for our purposes
we were focusing right now in this
population that maybe don't know as much
there may be coming to they don't know
and actually there's a second report
that we mock up that the Lindsay made
and that we implemented where it's the
sort of says this is general information
about mammograms and sort of not so much
about the breast cancer side of it but
just the availability and I actually
learned a lot this summer about
mammograms I I knew very little about
them before and I think that so right
right now in this age of testing we're
definitely going to err on the side of
caution sort of provide a lot of
information you know things like the
glossary making it very user friendly
but I think it's very difficult to
expect all the different kinds of users
that you might have and that's I there
were so many unexpected interesting
questions and the interviews to sort of
oh we didn't think of that or of course
maybe people don't know that you know
working on chess you I think surrounded
by healthcare culture it's difficult to
remember what what to basic knowledge
and what maybe isn't yes
no no
yeah there was a lot and I think both
and when just our team testing it sort
of seeing it and what was really i think
the most memorable probably was the
graphics which i know is he'll touch on
her presentation because those are
graphics and pictographs and so i think
they really stood out in people said
well this make sense or oh this doesn't
and i know that kind of fine-tuning
those took a long time but also smart
people and the glossary people just
stopped in and saying well what does
that mean i think i know what that means
but i'm not sure and sort of adding in
this plan language glossary to sort of
making it really easy for people to sort
of because i think the decision works
best when people are able to really
focus on what they think about
mammograms because it's a lot to do with
your defining their values and
everything and so if they're stopping
and starting and second-guessing
themselves it's sort of difficult I
think for them to remember why they're
using the app and i think i'm not
mistaken it saying that we really wanted
people to feel very comfortable using it
when you're in a doctor's office and
maybe really nervous about your
mammogram or nervous about breast cancer
I think and at least for me I really saw
that we all wanted women to really feel
comfortable and making this application
user friendly and even although the
other thing put the ipad the varying
levels of knowledge people had about
this new technology I think was was
surprising because I at my second job is
I work in a computer store work in a mac
store and so I've been surrounded by the
stuff for years and stepping back and
remembering that Oh which button does
this and there's no buttons and there's
no keyboard and how do I use this it's
of course people don't know and that was
really so interesting and surprising to
me to kind of step back and look at this
technology and how we use software from
a profit as perspective of people that
don't do it every day and our computer
science students so it was very
interesting is that interests your
question great
thank you
okay it's my pleasure to introduce to
you Lindsey Watson she has also been
working on care de nîmes project with
mammography decision aid and lindsey is
a recent graduate of Washington State
and this is her second summer internship
and she's much more than an intern she's
actually a research assistant go-to
person on the grant and she just knows
everything we all go to her so she's
going to talk more about the project
especially with the cognitive interview
piece of the project you so as
introduced I'm Lindsey Watson my mentors
are dr. Rai bar and dr. Eden and this is
as she said my second summer internship
here at de maiz and last year i did some
qualitative analysis work with dr. eden
with the original decision aid and this
year or the summer i am working on the
development of the new version for the
ipad mini so since Katie gave kind of a
nice explanation of the the background
of the decision aid I'll just focus on
my main project which was the cognitive
interviewing portion of the app
development and I'll also provide a
couple of examples of changes that
resulted from the feedback and talk a
little bit about what I learned during
this project and what the next steps are
for the for the app so over the last few
months my main project was to recruit 15
age and risk appropriate women and
interview them while they used the app
and at various stages of the development
I interviewed three to four women
individually and I spent about an hour
with each individual one and having them
go through the tool answer questions
about how usable it was
and their experience in just their
general feedback in using the tool and
as app development had progressed I
worked on writing a plain language copy
for the app and also making revisions in
the content management system so for the
interviews themselves they were
semi-structured we used a predetermined
set of questions and then we also ask
probing questions to clarify any
comments that they made because one of
the priorities in creating this app was
to ensure that the tool is accessible to
a wider audience one of our main goals
of the interviews was to make sure that
the information that we presented was
clear and understandable and because
breast cancer is such a sensitive
subject we also wanted to make sure that
we weren't causing any undue anxiety or
worry in the messages and the
information that we were presenting and
we also looked for feedback about the
usability of the tool and tracked how
long it took for the women to use the
tool and as you can imagine this process
is very iterative so with each round of
interviews we would go back and
implement the changes and redesign and
eval you reevaluate with a new group of
users
so just to give you an example in the
very first round of testing we presented
these for graphics depicting the same
information about false positives and
false negatives and to control for the
learning effect we showed them each in a
different order to each of the four
women and asked them to think aloud and
describe what they learned from the
image and we got a lot of feedback from
from all the four women about each
graphic from color choices to their
emotional responses to the images and
when we compared the comments
side-by-side it was clear to us which
image we would use in the future stages
so would anyone like to guess which
image we ended up using
bottom right yeah you're right so this
was the first draft of many versions of
what we're now using in the decision aid
at first glance it looks like it's
fairly clear it presents the information
it gives the breakdown and it looks like
something that most people would be able
to glean what were what we're trying to
convey but of course we had lots of
comments and feedback from the users and
we one of the one of the comments that
was made is that the two pink shades
were to close in that they should have
there should be more contrast between
the two one woman commented that the
boxes weren't balanced they were they
seemed off kilter the two bottom boxes
there and someone also suggested that we
use or that we provide the positive
information first meaning putting the
larger number of women they don't have
cancer above the number of women who do
have cancer and so this is the most
current version that we're using now
most of the changes came from the user
feedback we added more specific
information about the risk and age of
the women being screened we we did end
up moving the positive information to
the top we changed the colors so that
there's more contrast between normal and
abnormal see and we also balanced out
the boxes so you can see that there's
and this one for this graphic we were
intending to convey in a clever way that
we don't know which woman out of the 70
will get cancer or will get breast
cancer however we had two women in the
interviews who expressed that the
graphic made them feel uncomfortable and
one woman actually said that she felt
like it was a ticking time bomb ready to
go or preparing to go off counting down
and what's interesting to me is that
while we were trying to convey
uncertainty they were having this
anxiety and that was that was definitely
not the message that was being received
so too the solution was to slowly fade
to a question mark which still conveys
the same message but is much more gentle
and not so anxiety provoking and these
are just two examples of the many
changes and processes that we went
through just fine tuning the tool for an
audience with with limited literacy
which brings me to what I learned over
this summer internship this is my first
experience with app development so I
definitely learned a lot I specifically
learned that the app design process very
iterative and definitely fold surprises
and it was all so fascinating to see how
each team member contributed their own
expertise to the development of the tool
I worked with a variety of different
scientists doctors computer programmers
graphic designers who also have their md
it was that was one of the most
interesting parts was seeing how
everybody added their own contributions
and and last but not least I discovered
just how difficult it is to translate
complex health information to
into plain language for example I have
here if you try to define or explain
genetic a genetic mutation to somebody
who has limited experience with genetics
or might not even know what genes are
personally I when defining terms are
trying to explain something to someone
with say an eighth grade education level
I imagine talking to my 12 year old
nephews or I have some experience
teaching kindergartners so using that
sort of mindset of breaking things down
into very simple terms is not as easy as
it seems and we also had a numeracy
expert and an eighth-grade English
teacher who came in and helped us with
the with the plain language and a couple
of other tricks actually we had a style
manual for low health literacy and we
also used wikipedia which has a language
translator into plain language as one of
their languages on most of the most of
the pages over all the feedback from the
participants in experts was invaluable
in developing an evidence-based decision
aid that was accessible to women with
limited literacy skills and we are now
in the final stages we're just
fine-tuning the app we have one more
round of cognitive interviews before we
pre test on ten ten women and then we
will hopefully be going live in clinics
in late-september and after testing we
are eventually we would like to get the
memo pad as Katie mentioned out to the
public for use in clinics so thank you
to everybody that I worked with and D
mice for this opportunity and question
oh I'm question on your the color
choices how do you you know colors have
all kinds of you know implicit the
meanings to different people and I
noticed you know when you changed from
the two versions of paint to pink and
blue the the blue was the positive
results you know the negative test
results the good results in the pink was
the bad ones you know and it was that
feedback from the users or how was that
this decision made because it seems to
me it seems a little backwards but I'm
not the target audience so I kind of
wonder how it was in for um well I think
that we we stuck with pink and blue
because things like red and green are
fairly loaded and we wanted to stay away
from that positive and the negative
because if you if you look at the
graphic there we're not trying to say
that of all those normal results there
is still that abnormal there that one
woman with cancer and with the abnormal
results 98 don't have cancer so it's not
necessarily a good versus bad that we
were trying to to get across I guess
would be so I'm not exactly sure maybe
David or Michelle could could help on
why we chose blue I don't remember the
specific reason there was no real
specific rhyme or reason initially I
mean we started with the red-green
scheme you know fairly common
interpretation red bean bag green being
good but in further iterations we
thought it as mission you know Michelle
and Lindsey mentioned to us that you
know these are fairly loaded we don't
want to be suggesting things to people i
think it tested poorly initially to
someone commented about the red green
being bad so this started with like a
pink and pink but again as someone
mentioned they wanted higher contrast
between the colors so it was just a high
contrast color choice between the two
and then in further testing from there I
don't believe there was any comments
about the
after that point so you know it worked
so we stuck with it but you know there
was no specific blue means less pink
means this that we were trying to convey
yeah so a lot of people in this room
know that I'm always interested in
trying to find the connections between
the clinical and the bio side of our
program and I'm actually thinking I'm
thinking of your comment about people
having a hard time understanding what a
genetic mutation is and marks talk is in
the future clinicians will be presented
with you know multiple different gene
mutations that are going to influence
how we treat people you have any
thoughts on how you will convey that
sort of information to patients
especially you know lesser educated
patients in a decision aid and I think
that's definitely something that is
worth looking into I mean I have
personal experience going into like a
genetic counseling we're even that is is
way above an eighth grade literacy level
so and I think that on most health
literature is above an eighth-grade
literacy level so it is definitely
something that should be should be done
is to kind of break it down so that it's
more accessible to to wider audiences
that answers your question well I I
think it's a challenge for for us all
going forward
are the sizes of the circles
proportional and does the size influence
decision behavior that second question
is a really good question the your first
question we we did change the size of
the abnormal results to be more
proportionate because that was one of
the comments was that it seemed
disproportionate it is disproportionate
definitely in this so we did make that
change I don't think that it's exact but
yeah I mean it's not exactly i was
thinking about doing like this fancy
mathematics and calculated the volume
circumference and all that but it would
have just been like the screen space we
had if we made it that small and be
harder to present that information so
it's not that all proportionate well I
think it's interesting because you know
scientifically you might want to present
them as proportional but if you're
trying to convince users stacked in a
certain way or attacked in a value-based
way then it might make sense to make the
abnormal results bigger because the
impact of that result is bigger for the
users okay well I think what we tried to
stay away from is trying to guide them
towards the decision we're more trying
to present the information in as neutral
way as possible could you tell us more
excuse me more about your cognitive
interviews did you interview the same
subjects more than once um no we know we
had different groups for each we do have
some women on our minds to bring back
after we've made all the changes but
yeah it's been different groups each
time
all right thank you